a
[Música]
ah
españa es uno de los países con más
polarización política de europa según
señalan distintos estudios
internacionales una polarización que en
los últimos años se han nutrido sobre
todo del conflicto con cataluña pero que
ahora se centra en la gestión de la
pandemia del coronavirus uno de los
lugares donde son más patentes las
consecuencias de esta polarización es
aquí en la comunidad de madrid' y en la
constante confrontación entre el
gobierno regional liderado por el
partido popular la derecha tradicional
española con el gobierno central la
coalición entre el partido socialista y
unidas podemos sin embargo no se puede
comprender el clima político español sin
tener en cuenta las consecuencias de la
irrupción de la extrema derecha en las
instituciones donde despliegan
abiertamente su discurso racista y
fascista que al mismo tiempo alienta el
discurso del odio en las calles para
ponerles un ejemplo reciente hace un par
de meses en una sesión parlamentaria el
líder del partido de extrema derecha vox
santiago abascal se dirigió al
presidente del gobierno pedro sánchez
diciéndole que preside el peor gobierno
que ha tenido nuestro país en los
últimos 80 años periodo que comprende
evidentemente la dicta
franquista
la realidad es que en colombia nunca ha
gobernado una opción de izquierdas sin
embargo eso no impide una fuerte
polarización en el país por un lado las
élites de una sociedad de raíces
conservadoras que siempre han sabido
negociar entre ellas y por otra parte
las guerrillas que sí abrazaron la lucha
socialista pero también las luchas
campesinas indígenas afros estudiantiles
y en los últimos tiempos la feminista en
los últimos meses la tensión interna ha
crecido el ex presidente álvaro uribe
fue detenido domiciliariamente antes de
ser liberado en octubre por manipulación
de testigos y con sospechas de vínculos
con el paramilitarismo también en las
últimas semanas ha habido dos caravanas
a las que el presidente iván duque ha
decidido no acudir y dejado así de este
modo la popular silla vacía un ha sido
una mina indígena y la otra una caravana
de desmovilizados de las farc la
polarización pone en peligro la vida de
quien apostó por la paz desde 2016 236
desmovilizados han sido asesinados
mientras que indígenas líderes sociales
y ambientales también sufren la
violencia en primera persona con 95
líderes sociales muertos en el primer
semestre de 2020 un 61 por ciento más
que en
en chile los resultados del histórico
plebiscito del pasado 25 de octubre
mostraron más que la polarización de la
sociedad chilena la profunda división
que existe entre los distintos grupos
sociales mientras que como sabemos en la
prueba se impuso de forma categórica con
el 78% de los votos hubo tan sólo 5
comunas en todo el país donde ganó el
rechazo tres de ellas se encuentran en
los barrios más adinerados de la capital
de santiago en la línea imaginaria que
tradicionalmente ha dividido la parte
pobre de la ciudad y el aporte rica que
es la que nos encontramos plaza italia
conocida también por ser el centro
neurálgico de las manifestaciones los
barrios más acomodados se encuentran
siempre hacia el sector oriente de la
capital y es ahí donde se concentró el
rechazo en las condes vitacura y lo
barnechea los barrios donde vive el 85
por ciento del 1% más poderoso del país
las élites que mostraron así una gran
desconexión con los intereses y deseos
del resto de la sociedad chilena y
también un cierto miedo a perder los
privilegios que han disfrutado en las
últimas décadas
[Música]